As superheroes continue to defeat the forces
of evil – and their competition at the box
office – more and more DC and Marvel comics
characters are getting their chance to shine
on the big screen.
The Justice League and Avengers take care
of the most world famous heroes, but what
about the characters who are just as powerful,
popular or important – but nowhere near
as well known?
Some of the best comic stories are yet to
be told, assuming the studios know where to
look.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Underrated Superheroes
Who Deserve Their Own Movies.
Martian Manhunter
A super powered alien marooned on Earth is
a story comic fans have heard dozens of times.
But when Superman refers to Martian Manhunter
as “the most powerful being on the face
of the Earth,” he is clearly deserving of
more than a supporting role.
The story of just how J’onn J’onzz, the
last surviving Green Martian came to Earth
has changed over the years, but the important
points remain the same: J’onn lost his wife
and family, wound up on Earth, and decided
to help those who couldn’t help themselves.
Also, he’s one of the most powerful heroes
in the DC Universe.
Able to fly, read minds, phase through objects,
become invisible, change his shape and density,
and regrow himself from a single hand.
Manhunter obviously became a staple of the
animated Justice League, but if you ask us,
Bruce Wayne admitting that J’onn is basically
a combination of Batman and Superman means
leaving him out of DC’s movie universe would
be a colossal mistake.
Darkhawk
In the modern age of unmanned aircraft and
military drones, the superhero Darkhawk may
not be as groundbreaking as he used to be.
Even so, the story of a teenager who finds
a mysterious amulet that allows him to pilot
an extra-dimensional android is a big screen
hit just waiting to be told.
The teenager Chris Powell may lack the name
recognition of Tony Stark, but his suit of
armor is even more powerful, even if he's
not actually wearing it into battle.
If Marvel plans to keep pushing their technology,
alien scheming, and cosmic plot lines - while
bringing in younger fans with Spider-Man - then
a Darkhawk appearance in the MCU would be
an unexpected, but potentially brilliant twist.
Captain Comet
The Cosmic side of the DC Universe may be
dominated by Darkseid and the Green Lantern
Corps, but the supporting cast in the colourful
corners of space are just as important - and
few are as interesting as Captain Comet.
Created between the Gold and Silver ages of
comic books, Adam Blake was one of the first
fictional mutant heroes, introduced over a
decade before Marvel's X-Men.
Blessed with superhuman strength, psychic
and telekinetic powers, Blake took up the
Comet name to fight crime, before exploring
the galaxy.
Comet returned to the DC spotlight in the
2006 series "Mystery in Space," which saw
the hero uncovering the mystery of his own
resurrection on Hardcore Station, an intergalactic
hive of criminals and drifters.
If DC wants to match Marvel's Guardians of
the Galaxy or the return of Star Wars, this
is one space based hero that could do the
job - without dealing with the universe's
biggest cosmic villains.
Beta Ray Bill
The Avengers can throw some mean punches,
but only one of them wields the power of a
god.
So when Thor first came across an alien spaceship
headed for Earth, he was more than surprised
to find a being on board that could match
him blow for blow.
The alien was none other than Beta Ray Bill,
one of the last survivors of the Korbinite
race, placed into a body resembling a horse-like
animal from his homeworld.
After claiming Thor's Hammer for himself,
the pair would grow to respect each other
as noble warriors, with Odin giving Bill a
hammer just as powerful as the god of thunder's.
The horse-faced warrior went on to become
a fan-favourite and a serious weapon in Marvel's
cosmic wars, even starting a romance with
Lady Sif.
If Chris Hemsworth wants to hang up his cape
any time soon, or crosses paths with Marvel's
alien races, handing the spotlight to Beta
Ray Bill would be a dream come true for comic
fans.
Moon Knight
Some may write him off as a rip-off of Batman,
but Marvel's supernatural Moon Knight is anything
but.
When former US Marine and professional boxer
Marc Spector found himself working as a mercenary
in the sands of Egypt, a run-in with valuable
artifacts - and his fellow hired guns - leaves
him lifeless in front of a statue of Khonshu,
the Egyptian Moon God.
Offering to return Marc to life if he acts
as his living Avatar, the Moon god blesses
him with superhuman strength tied to the phases
of the moon, and a shroud of bright white
cloth.
It isn't all just hunting criminals, though,
since the gift splits Marc's personality into
pieces, making him even more of a wild card
in Iron Man and Captain America's Civil War
standoff.
The bottom line is that even Taskmaster, the
deadly copycat of Marvel's universe, refuses
to mimic the Moon Knight’s fighting style.
Why?
Because he'd rather take a punch than block
it, with each hit seen as penance for the
pain he caused in his former life.
Who knew someone could make Batman seem well-balanced?
Union Jack
In the Marvel movie universe, you don't need
a superpower to be an effective fighter in
the war between good and evil.
But as the studio's plans grow, there's no
time like the present to introduce a European
operative - even better, one who fights not
just terrorist threats, but supernatural ones.
There are three men who have used the name
of Union Jack, from wealthy British aristocrats
fighting in costume during World War 1 and
2, to a commoner lucky enough to wear the
famous costume.
He may not be a super soldier, but Jack could
easily fit into the ranks of SHIELD's top
agents.
And if Marvel wants to wade into supernatural
horror, the hero's long history with vampires
and the occult makes him the perfect candidate.
Zatanna
The Justice League may feature a super powered
alien, an Amazonian demigod, and a super speedster,
but they all share the same weakness: magic.
And when it comes to sorcerers, Zatanna Zatara
is hard to beat.
Uttering magical spells in battle against
DC's deadliest villains is one thing, but
when wounded enough to put normal magicians
out of a fight, Zatanna has even resorted
to writing out spells in her own blood – how’s
that for dedication?
Knowing that Warner Bros will be bringing
magic into their movie universe, Zatanna's
power, experience with the League, and history
with John Constantine makes her a no-brainer
for a starring role.
Nightwing
Ask any comic fan, and they’ll tell you
that calling Dick Grayson ‘Batman’s sidekick’
is selling him short.
As Robin the Boy Wonder, Dick used his time
under Batman’s wing to master dozens of
martial arts and languages.
But he was destined for greater things, becoming
the leader of the Teen Titans, before deciding
a new name was needed for his solo career.
Remembering Superman’s stories of the Kryptonian
crimefighter Nightwing, Dick set his sights
on Bludhaven, a city in need of a protector
just as Batman had watched over Gotham.
But it wasn’t just Dick’s fighting skills
that made him effective.
When DC’s New 52 saw Grayson unmasked to
the world, Batman convinced him to fake his
own death, and take up a career as a secret
agent, launching the brand new comic series
“Grayson.”
Knowing that Zack Snyder’s Justice League
movie universe features a version of Batman
who’s been fighting crime for decades, we
have to believe a plan for Dick Grayson is
in place – if not as a masked vigilante,
then as a covert operative gathering intel
for the Dark Knight.
The Question
Vic Sage was living the typical life of any
famous reporter, before a close friend gave
him a tip he couldn't resist.
To thwart the black market sale of of an artificial
skin, Sage covers his own face with the product,
and ambushes the men behind the crime.
Realizing that hiding his famous face will
let him uncover crimes - and stop them himself
- he takes a new name: The Question.
Audiences are used to masked vigilantes, but
a DC hero with a passion for journalism, beating
criminals for information, not ‘justice’
– would be a welcome change.
Blurring the line between normal reporting
and a ‘supernatural sleuth’ — with the
audience in on the joke – The Question is
too unique a hero to pass up.
Doctor Fate
If there’s one character whose absence from
the big screen is downright criminal, it has
to be
Doctor Fate.
The name refers to the helmet worn by the
hero more than the person underneath
it, having been passed down to a half-dozen
people throughout DC’s history and alternate
Earths.
Uncovered in the tomb of the ancient god Nabu
the Wise, the original Fate was trained
in the ways of magic from the god himself,
blessing him with a golden cape and costume
to
wear along with his signature helmet.
Granting the wearer not just magical attacks,
but
superhuman strength, flight, and invulnerability,
the Helmet of Fate has been a major factor
in
too many storylines to count.
Every comic fan is sure to have their favorite
version, but with the
hero’s popularity in the comics, animated
series, and even the TV series Smallville,
the lack of a
major movie role is a problem that DC’s
supernatural-focused movies will hopefully
solve.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite or most underrated
superheroes?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.